we're already in the first week of March
so it's time for me to do another
monthly update video I'll talk about
what we've got coming up in March and
what you might have missed in the month
of February so I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things from my
viewers fan subscribers here they are
big thing number one here in Milwaukee
we have established a local chapter of
Sofia that is the Society of
philosophers in America we'll talk more
about that in the March portion of this
big thing number two closely related we
will be having our first Sofia sponsored
event here in Milwaukee on the 17th
where do you justice and kindness meet
we'll have a public discussion followed
by a more intensive discussion focused
on Cicero's on duties big thing number
three not related to those two but
happening the day after that event I
will be participating in a stoicism and
creativity roundtable event with my
friend and collaborator Scott to rouille
of Berklee School of Music and it'll be
hosted by by Scott Perry the stoic
creative so that's what we've got coming
up a lot of other stuff as well that
we'll talk about in just a minute all
right before we get into what's coming
up in March let's talk about what went
on in February wasn't that productive a
month for me in part because it's
shorter than all the other months I also
was continuing some pretty for me
intensive working out which is you know
paying dividends but also taking quite a
bit of time on my part and Andy and I
both got sick at certain points which
cut into some of my getting stuff done
energies particularly towards the end of
the day on quite a few evenings so I did
give a number of talks and hosted some
events one that that people may be
particularly interested in the
philosophers in the midst of history we
continued our third
of that and we had a session on Cicero
Greek philosophy in the fall of the
Roman Republic I also continued our
worlds of speculative fiction series
this time we talked about Fritz LIBOR
and the Father and the great Mouser
series that was a lot of fun we did
philosophy pop ups on the topic of
stoicism romantic love and relationships
I held an AMA that is asking me anything
session did an online philosophy chat
with my patreon supporters and hosted my
monthly half-hour Hegel Q&A and
discussion sessions online as well you
might have also seen some podcast
episodes come out where I came on as a
guest did three of them actually came
out this month one with zero books
podcast another with the death hang out
guys and the third one with the
practical stoic
I also published quite a bit in in blogs
you know both in Iraq sister you know at
TK my main blog a little bit of stuff in
half hour Hegel and I published a peace
and stoicism today specifically on
stoicism erotic love and relationships
since it's you know Valentine's Day and
in February and that's got a lot of
discussion engaged in a bit of other
writing projects as well I'm still
working you know plugging away at that
stoicism and in accordance with nature
book don't know if that'll be done by
the end of the year but but sooner than
later hopefully and I'm working on
taking the videos from that I did on
epictetus doing a very close reading
commentary on the enchiridion and
turning those into a book as well taking
you know what I said in the videos and
going through and cleaning it up a
little bit also you know did a bit more
work on the Aristotle categories course
it's not yet ready to air but hopefully
will be coming out
is coming month and I engaged in a lot
of tutorial work philosophical
counseling and coaching and quite a bit
of consulting and content production as
well for for clients if you're
interested in those things by the way
you can always check out the reason IO
website or just email me directly at
Greg at reason IO calm what else did we
do in February
well I shot some videos and I did create
a new set of videos which took a bit of
time away from doing some of the other
video stuff and these were these short
Q&A videos the first four of which were
all on stoicism I'll probably stick with
stoicism topics for for a bit more
although there's plenty of other
interesting topics to address as well
got some more sasural core concept
videos shot and uploaded did videos of
course of the events which you can see
link to below and I only got five
half-hour hagel videos done this last
month unfortunately I was shooting four
four six which is my quota but it didn't
didn't quite make it so I blame it on
the short month anyway that's February
alright so what's coming up in March
March fortunately is a much longer month
31 days but we're already five days in
so so I've got a lot of stuff to crank
out I already held one of the events for
the month one of the philosophy pop ups
you can see the video for that link to
below the topics for the pop ups this
month are justice and kindness and the
interconnection between them in part
piggybacking off of the event later this
month but before we get to that on March
6th 5 p.m. Central Time
we'll be having our public half-hour
Haegele Q&A and discussion session you
don't have to be a patreon supporter to
participate in that you don't actually
have to know very much about Haegele if
you just want to show up and ask
questions or listen to the other
participants chat that's perfectly fine
we do give priority to angle related
questions but
we often talk about a lot of other stuff
on March 8th here locally at the
Brookfield Public Library
we continue our at 7:00 p.m. we continue
our worlds of speculative fiction series
this time focusing on certain novels by
Robert Heinlein in particular Starship
Troopers the moon is a harsh mistress
Methuselah stilled Rijn and a few other
I mean I think I wrote so much so I'm
sure that stuff is going to come up as
well
on the 10th at 2:00 p.m. I'll be having
my philosophy chat which is a perk for
some of my patreon supporters if you'd
like to become a patreon supporter you
can see the link below you can also see
it in the cards up in the corner of the
video that's something it's sort of an
open at a discussion that I do for them
where they get to ask me about anything
that they want to and then on the 17th
Saint Patrick's Day at 1:30 running to
about 4 o'clock so you know if you're
here in the Milwaukee area and and you
want to do something before getting you
know festive for st. Patty's we're
having our first public Sophia event
Sophia is the Society of philosophers in
America it's devoted to doing public
philosophy taking philosophy out of the
Academy and and bringing it into the
marketplace into businesses into public
discussions the sort of thing that I am
really a big fan of we will be looking
at the question of where do justice and
kindness meet and we'll start with a
community discussion and then in the
second hour of it after taking a short
break I will be leading a more intensive
discussion of Cicero's on duties and his
discussions of how justice and kindness
map on to each other there and the
connections to the other virtues so if
you're here in the area or if you're in
the Chicago area Madison area Fox cities
come on down we're happy to have you
here and if you want you can become a
member of Sophia at the event on the
18th day after that
two p.m. Central Time 3:00 p.m. Eastern
I will be a participant in that Stoicism
and creativity roundtable I think many
of you may already know Scott truly you
know from the conversation that I had
with him Scott is is a good friend of
mine somebody who's equally interested
in in metal pedagogy Aristotle stoicism
and we're gonna have a great discussion
he's also an amazing guitar player as
well which is something that we don't
share comment I'm an amateur banjo and
bass player but that's gonna be hosted
by Scott Perry so that should be a
really fun discussion on the 24th 12
p.m. I'll be hosting my ask me anything
session everybody can just show up and
ask me about anything that you like
can't guarantee that I'll actually get
it in since so many people ask me
questions but if you show up early
you'll probably get your question there
right away
and then we finish up the month on the
29th at 6:00 p.m. here locally at the
Shorewood Public Library with the Mk II
that is Milwaukee stoic fellowship so
you know that's another great
organization they by the way our
co-sponsoring the Sophia event because
it is connected to stoicism so we've got
some nice coming together there got a
lot of great stuff happening here in the
Milwaukee area you know those of you who
are local you should show up and and if
you do you know introduce yourself to me
if your viewer and yeah well we'll chat
afterwards what else is coming up in in
March there may or may not be some
podcast things coming up we'll have to
see depends on when they're releasing
some stuff I do have some recorded
material out there waiting for people to
release and I might be doing some
additional stuff as well be hitting the
writing projects pretty heavily this
month I've got a lot of stuff not just
the book projects but other you know
blog writing to do and hopefully getting
to some
articles that I've wanted to work on for
quite some time
I'm also gonna be working on the online
classes in the reason IO Academy trying
to get that material finished and get
those classes open and released for
people to sign up for them if you want
to see what we've got available right
now we do have some excellent classes
already available you can check that out
by looking at the link below last thing
I'll talk about is videos what am I
going to be doing this month well I want
to do some more of those QA things but I
don't want them to not having me do book
reviews because I do still have all
those books stacked up that I want to
get done and I do have a few things that
I think I may want to get on Sandler's
soapbox about those of you who know
about that rant series
quite a few things going on in the news
that I think merits some attention core
concept videos all I think I'll finish
up with sister Rosa on duties and then
start in on some Heidegger maybe do some
stuff on the introduction being in time
that I had promised to do awhile back
and we'll have the event videos of
course and then the six half-hour Hagel
videos and that will take me through to
the end of the month the last thing that
I'll mention is you know we're still
looking to fill up the calendar for
later this year for speaking engagements
or you know other sorts of on-site gigs
if you're interested in having me come
and speak for your your organization
institution group send me an email at
Gregg at reason IO and and we'll start
talking about it likewise if you're
interested in workshops or consulting if
you're if you need somebody to help you
understand particular philosophical
topics you might want to check out my
tutorial services if you want some help
applying philosophy to work through life
issues then you might want to check out
my philosophical consulting so glad
March is a long month be
there's a ton of stuff to get done
during march and hope all of you have a
great month
you